las protestas en la india se
intensifican contra un nuevo proceso de
reclutamiento militar el acceso a las
fuerzas armadas es la última esperanza
de miles de jóvenes para obtener una
fuente de ingreso pero esta medida
genera incertidumbre entre los
aspirantes al ejército solo puede
reclutar 46 miles de personas entre 17 y
21 años para 4 años y el 75% de ellos se
jubilarán obligatoriamente al fin de
este periodo sin ninguna prestación
los jóvenes sueñan con alistarse en el
ejército pero este nuevo sistema
contractual ha supuesto un gran revés
para los jóvenes así que ahora la
demanda es que el gobierno detenga a
esta dictadura y no introduzca un
sistema contractual en el ejército con
7 estados indios registraron brotes de
violencia durante las protestas dejando
un muerto y varios heridos
los jóvenes dañaron numerosas
propiedades e incendiaron vagones de
tren interrumpiendo los servicios en la
región durante varias horas
los daños a las propiedades públicas
están causando pérdidas millonarias si
los manifestantes se habían manifestado
pacíficamente habría sido aceptable pero
la violencia no ayuda a nadie a los
partidos de la oposición y algunos
miembros del partido de moody han
criticado la reforma diciendo que al
sistema conducirá más desempleo en el
país que ya se encuentra en una tasa del
7.5 por ciento según el centro para el
seguimiento de la economía india en
vista de las críticas el ministro de
defensa de la india anunció este viernes
que aumentará dicho límite de edad para
aceptar el ingreso de jóvenes de hasta
23 años